[Musique]
ce soir
sept ans plus tard la saga d'eau
contaminée se poursuit à shannon je lui
ai toujours
je n'abandonnerai jamais jusqu'à ce
qu'on ait gain quand des centaines de
cancer dans une petite communauté
les citoyens de shannon ont été exposés
à un cancérigène et donc ils ont subi un
projet de 6 mai selon la santé publique
c'est une trop petite population pour
établir un lien entre l'eau contaminée
et ses codes cancer ce que ça veut dire
que les options populations sont
condamnés à pas avoir d' études de
qualité très bonne question que je
répondrais des citoyens qui se sentent
abandonnés
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
il y a neuf ans à enquête on vous
racontait le drame des gens de la petite
communauté de shannon près de québec
l'euro était contaminée par un produit
hautement toxique
en fait il y avait plusieurs dépotoir à
ciel ouvert sur le site de la fabrique
de munitions dans lesquels on déversait
toutes sortes de produits chimiques et
camions réculé ici il tempère il a
répété comme duo veau sauce allait
tranquillement et avec l'appui mais tout
se serait plaint le chat est sorti du
sac
en décembre 2000 après que snc est
analysée loup dupuis d'un de ses
employés qui habitait à shannon
on a une lettre à notre porte nous dit
vainqueur les puits risquait d'être
contaminés par du tc e trichloréthylène
et qu'il fallait ne pas boire de l'eau
ouvrir la fenêtre quand rené ladouce ils
servent droite demoiselle vachon mais à
lui eu un cancer du côlon puis
possiblement un cancer du cerveau en
même temps je partais l'eau au moins
huit heures par jour bêta 1 m 10 heures
l'eau à aller travailler que je consomme
impôts c'est trop lourd mais eux c'est à
tout le temps à l'école à la garderie à
la mère laisse parler l'oise et les
jeunes dans cette issue tout était le
chalet santé publique deux fois puis
leur ai demandé deux fois je voudrais
avoir une étude épidémiologique pions
pour voulu une étude menée sur un
village où si petit que shannon
risquerait de créer inutilement la
panique
sont-ce massue cette population là
pendant 20 ans ça va coûter tellement
cher qui a pas un gouvernement qui voit
sa embarquer là dedans c'est de savoir
des millions et des millions de dollars
pour aboutir tout le temps de
l'incertitude je veux que gouvernement
du canada reconnaît sa responsabilité et
qu'il assume les conséquences
cette contamination là tant au niveau
monétaire que de la santé des citoyens
ça devrait de sainte-marie mode on
découvre que l'eau est contaminée au tc
eux qui est un produit hautement toxique
cancérigène
les gens boivent de l'eau ils sont
persuadés que l'apparition de cancers
c'est directement lié à la contamination
et ça fait 17 ans que les citoyens de
shannon attendent qu'on reconnaisse ce
lien et penser que la direction de la
santé publique mènerait une étude et
qu'enfin on confirme risque pour eux est
tout à fait évident évident mais pas si
évident que ça justement est ce soir on
va vous révéler le bras de fer qui se
joue entre les citoyens et la santé
publique
palais de justice de québec
driss d'eux des citoyens de shannon se
retrouve de nouveau face à la défense
nationale et à deux entreprises privées
cet épidémiologiste et leur nouvel allié
ces travaux s'oppose à une étude de la
direction santé publique
voici son directeur il est ici comme
témoin à la demande du procureur général
les combattant de la première heure sont
l'âme animés par la même éducation ya
des gens qui sont morts il ya des gens
qui sont atteints de cancer encore
aujourd'hui qui souffrent il ya des
jeunes ya des enfants - entre derrière
chaque dose piège peut mettre un visage
peut mettre une famille encore là il ya
deux semaines une jeune dame de 52 ans
qui est décédée d'un cancer du côlon 52
ans
les citoyens avaient intenté un recours
collectif
mais dans le jugement de 2012 le lien
entre l'exposition au trichloroéthylène
le pcr et leurs problèmes de santé n'a
pas été reconnue il demande maintenant
la cour d'appel de se pencher sur une
nouvelle preuve
la chaîne on veut savoir si haut risque
si les gens qui ont été en contact avec
le trichloréthylène en plus de chances
de développer un cancer que les autres
c'est ça qu'on veut savoir on n'a jamais
eu de rapports de la santé publique
marie paule spieser et la présidente du
regroupement des citoyens de shannon
alors avancé le fuyard est le plus haut
taux de fonte et il a même vu 1200 mg
par litre
c'est largement supérieur à la norme qui
est aujourd'hui de 5 mg ce puits se
trouve directement au dessus du panache
de contamination
une modélisation démontre comment le tc
assez répandu sous les résidences du
quartier
cette zone s'appelle le triangle rouge
il y a dix sept ans la petite ville de
shannon près de québec découvre que la
base militaire valcartier a déversé le
degré sans toxiques dans l'eau potable
pendant des décennies vous n'avez pas
aviser la population de shannon je
trouve que c'est un standard monsieur
jean bernier et l'encyclopédie vivante
du regroupement des citoyens
six salles ouvert en 1938 c'est elle
l'arsenal du canada faisaient de la
munition à la proche de la deuxième
guerre mondiale ou
rachetée différents produits chimiques
entre autres le trichloroéthylène qui
avec les années paires collet jusqu'à la
nappe phréatique
ça va ma droite sous shannon jusqu'à la
rivière jacques-cartier et puis chanel
toutes les résidences avaient le plus
privé avec ses devenus les plus
contaminée au trichloroéthylène les
résidences ont depuis été raccordé à
l'aqueduc municipal mini citoyens côtoie
toujours les vestiges de cette usine de
munitions
elle est laissée à l'abandon sur un
terrain qui n'a jamais été décontaminés
les membres du regroupement des citoyens
se tendent et est ce que la santé
publique les aide à trouver un lien
entre le tc eux et les nombreux cas de
cancer dans la communauté
mais leurs espoirs ont été déçus pendant
un porteur du tout quand le sapeur
substance
un dégraisseur mais cancérigènes alors
là je suis allé à santé publique québec
je pourrais dire suis très très bien au
début parce que comme mon dieu un
emmerdeur un peu danseurs le dr claude
juneau un mort c'est un véritable
travail de moine au début des années
2000 il a recueilli les dossiers
médicaux de près de 500 patients
atteints de cancer car le soumit à
penser aux patients qui avaient traité
puis principalement dans les rues qui
sont autour de sylob ce soit et un juno
que ce soit quand louis ce soit kings
drive la station
je faisais le tour des maisons l'aveu du
cancer dans toutes les maisons à peu
près le prix maison depuis des années
ces citoyens demandent à la santé
publique de mener une recherche
épidémiologique l'épidémiologie c'est
l'analyse des facteurs qui ont un impact
sur la santé des populations et je
partage l'angoissé des citoyens face aux
risques à la santé qui l'ont vécu
jusqu'ici la santé publique se limite à
mener des analyses sommaires sur la
fréquence des cancers à shannon selon
lesquelles il est impossible de conclure
à un problème particulier
le docteur françois desbiens s'appuie
sur les arguments de l'institut national
de santé publique du québec
il y est né ce pécule pour refuser les
demandes répétées des citoyens
la réponse que j'ai eu après avoir
consulté les outils national de santé
publique c'est que c'est pas possible de
faire une étude épidémiologique c'est
pas qu'on ne veut pas pourquoi parce que
la population est trop petit exposé on
n'a pas la puissance statistique
une population trop petit pour obtenir
des résultats concluants
c'est l'argument que la santé publique
évoquent depuis le début de cette saga
pour justifier son refus d'une étude
épidémiologique
on a toujours eu les mêmes réponses ses
portes faisable je pense que c'est un
manque de volonté de la part de santé
publique j'ai l'impression que c'est un
peu ce qu'on sait pas ça fait pas mal
mais non justement moi je les veux les
réponses moi c'est ce que j'aurais aimé
que santé publique face qui pousse plus
les recherches sur le trichloréthylène
pour qu'on soit capable justement de
faire le lien avec d'autres cancers
comme celui par exemple du cancer du
cerveau
chantal mallett a voulu fuir shannon
elle est partie s'installer à
yellowknife
après la mort de son fils alexandre le
cancer du cerveau agressif qui le
rongeait l'a finalement emporté en
février 2009 il n'avait que 18 ans je
trouve ça difficile par moments le fait
que toute l'histoire d'alexandre était
tellement médiatique
un moment donné je me sentais prix j'ai
tout fait le buzz j'avais de la misère à
composer avec tout ça fait que je me
suis pas blessé ça peu de bon sens et
les revenus dans la région pour revoir
des amis et suivre les audiences au
tribunal
une façon d'honorer une promesse faite à
son fils je lui ai toujours promis que
je ne le laisserai jamais tomber que je
n'abandonnerai jamais jamais cette cause
là que je la suivrai de près jusqu'à ce
qu'on ait game cause 17 cas de cancer du
cerveau sont recensés par le docteur
juneau les citoyens inquiets se tournent
de nouveau vers la santé publique lors
de la rencontre 2010 avec les citoyens
où on leur donnait la copie du rapport
qui fait état d' du suivi des cancers
puis on leur disait même à nos plus dans
la communauté pour l'arrêt toutes
explications qu'ils étaient déçus pas
les garder bien on n'a rien mais plus
mais d'altedia savez vous qu'on a
beaucoup de cancers du cerveau dans
notre communauté
parmi tous les cancers que dr juneau que
deux journées soient dépistés on a
beaucoup beaucoup mon jeu que j'ai
acquiescé c'est terminé tout d'agrégats
parce que j'avais des citoyens inquiets
pour du cancer du cerveau
la santé publique accepte enfin de
réaliser une étude dont l'objectif est
de déterminer s'il ya un excès de
cancers à shannon elle se penche sur le
cancer du cerveau mais aussi sur les
cancers du rein et du foie et sur le
lymphome non hodgkinien
de plus la dsp nomme un comité conseil
complètement indépendant son mandat est
notamment d'approuver les conclusions de
l'étude
quand santé publique en a annoncé la
mise en place d'un comité d'experts on a
reçu les cv des experts cet
impressionnant choisi mais mais mais
c'est finalement ya quelqu'un qui
connaisse à qui vaut qui va s'intéresser
à shannon pian à la vie des citoyens en
avril 2016 la santé publique accouche
finalement de son rapport est ce que le
nombre de cancers du cerveau observé est
plus important que celui attendu la
réponse est non il ne s'agit pas
d'établir un lien de cause à effet entre
les cas de cancers recensés sur ce
territoire et la présence de
trichloroéthylène dans la nappe d'eau
souterraine
l'étude conclut qu'il n'ya pas plus de
cancers à shannon qu'ailleurs elle juge
qu'il est inutile de poursuivre les
travaux
la santé publique ne sera pas de trouver
un lien de causalité si important aux
yeux des citoyens
249% plus de risque de cancer dans le
secteur qui a été exposée c'est la
conclusion de l'expert des citoyens
[Musique]
j'ai posé une question au directeur de
la santé publique parce que j'étais très
inquiet puis je lui ai dit mais qu'est
ce que vous allez allez dire aux
citoyens de shining les gens vont penser
qu' il tout simplement pas de problème
que y en a jamais eu et qui en aura
jamais puis il m'a répondu qu' il était
que c'était lui qui prenait les
décisions qu'il était très à l'aise avec
la méthode qui avait employés pour y
arriver les terrains d'épidémiologistes
comparer des fréquences de problèmes de
santé ou de cancer dans deux groupes un
groupe exposé cargo non exposés au moins
groupe n'explose - moins exposés par
exemple aux trembles et le représentant
des citoyens au sein du comité conseil
il a un doctorat en épidémiologie et en
toxicologie
en fait la direction de santé publique
voulait uniquement regardez donc la
fréquence des cancers dans cette
population et la comparer avec la
fréquence attendu en relation avec la
population québécoise et nous on leur
disait oh no du portrait que vous
dressez il faut vraiment aller un peu
plus loin
évaluer s'il vous plaît le risque en
lien avec l'exposition le comité conseil
envoie à la santé publique une
proposition unanime isoler la population
du fameux triangle rouge et comparé
l'incidence des cancers dans ce secteur
avec celle d'une population à shannon
qui n'a pas été exposé au tc y avait
aucune ouverture le directeur de santé
publique nous le dit simplement
j'entends votre proposition
je n'y répondrai pas ces gens là vont
demander rapidement de tenir compte de
l'exposition
oui il voulait établir un lien causal et
se dit on peut pas juste faire une étude
descriptive vous avez eu à plusieurs
reprises des demandes comme des concerts
entre les données que vous demandez
l'exposition n'est pas disponible
on n'a aucune capacité de savoir au
cours des 50 dernières
et quelle était la concession précise
alain la pratique et encore moins de
savoir qu'est-ce qui coulé des robinets
des personnes on se connaît pratiquement
jamais la dose la russie est excellent
et épidémiologiste en pédiatrie au
centre hospitalier universitaire de
sherbrooke
elle fait partie du comité conseil
chargé d'appuyer les travaux de la santé
publique
il y avait deux expertises des
ingénieurs qui ont analysé les panaches
ils ont modélisé à peu près là combien
cette communauté a reçu un total de ces
oeufs
pour moi c'est déjà ben ali et je prends
un contaminant dans votre sens la
concentration que je mesure maintenant
ça ne reflète pas tout la dose que vous
avez absorbé pendant des années mais je
peux le monde elysées dans son étude la
santé publique a regroupé les secteurs
exposés et non explosées pour les
comparer à l'ensemble du québec
selon des membres du comité conseil cela
dilue les résultats voilà pourquoi on
n'a pas trouvé plus de cancers à shannon
qu'ailleurs vous avez pris toute la
population de shannon et vous l'avez
comparer avec la population du québec
maintenant que on appris ce que les fish
n 10 assists nous permettait de faire
que beaucoup de militaires dans ce coin
d'eau il n'y faire ça à l'extérieur du
québec et on n'avait pas les régissent
de santé dans les autres provinces au
fédéral qui nous aurait permis de
diminuer les pertes de dieu on est
limité par les sources d'information que
nous avons les fiches administratifs
vont compter
la localisation des instituts et les
problèmes de santé qu'ils ont c'est ce
qu'on avait la population est trop petit
pour ce faire on n'aurait jamais la
puissante éthique pour ce faire on
utiliser la méthode qui étaient
disponibles avec la fiabilité
scientifique juste prendre toute la
musicalité de shannon comparé au québec
n'avaient pas beaucoup de sens dans
cette situation là larissa texert est
formel on n'a pas fait la bonne étude si
une étude qui ne répond pas à la bonne
question
il rappelait tube de gregor on le fait
quand on n'a pas de on n'a pas d'idée
qu'est ce qui pourrait causer une
situation
la question était pas que est-ce que
nous avons plus de cancers que le reste
du québec
la question était est ce que certaines
séquences air et surtout dans la zone
contaminée sont plus élevé que le reste
ne change à la demande des citoyens
claude tremblay utilise des données
partielles auxquels il a accès dans une
version préliminaire du rapport
il compare le secteur de shannon avec
celui de courcelette j'ai comparé mois
la population du groupe chan qui
contient en quelque sorte les gens
exposés au tc 1 en particulier les gens
qui sont dans le triangle rouge avec des
gens qui eux sont moins exposés donc
sont un secteur pour cela
alors au lieu dé mettre en relation avec
la population québécoise je les ai mis
en relation le avec l'autre un groupe
exposé par rapport à un couple ont
exposé et ses conclusions sont
percutantes 249% plus de risques de
développer un cancer dans le secteur
exposé pousser son étude
il aurait voulu avoir accès aux données
complètes de la santé publique nous du
comité scientifique nous avons demandé à
la direction de santé publique la
possibilité d'avoir la banque de données
pour l'exploiter et l'explorer de façon
adéquate selon nos compétences
qu'est-ce que ça arrive ça qu une fin de
non recevoir également espèrent les gens
de shannon sont pas les seuls à vivre
non il ya une situation semblable aux
états unis sur une base militaire qui
s'appelle camp lejeune il ya plusieurs
personnes qui nous en ont parlé
notamment des scientifiques comme claude
tremblay sont très intéressés par les
études sont réalisées là bas et ça doit
aussi inspirer les gens de shannon tout
à fait il ya des militants la bac sont
particulièrement inspirant pour les
personnes de shannon il mène toute une
bataille sur le front politique et ils
ont remporté des victoires à s'éclatant
de ces dernières années et vous êtes
allé voir de plus près ce qui se passe
là bas on vous emmène là tout de suite
après la pause
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
camp lejeune et tout mon porte en baisse
de 8,1 caroline du nord thomas shannon
des produits toxiques dont le
trichloroéthylène fillon ferait des
ravages
les nominés leurs familles ont consommé
de l'eau contaminée des années 50
jusqu'à la fin des années 80
[Musique]
nous nous sommes rendu à camp lejeune
les autorités ont décliné notre demande
d'entrevue
mais elles ont accepté de nous faire
visiter les lieux
mais
aujourd'hui rien ne laisse deviner
l'ampleur de la contamination
sauf peut-être quelques puits qui se
font discrets pour comprendre ce qu'il
s'est passé sur cette base il faut aller
à hilla btan à 140 km de là zhang ou
navires génie eh bien elle était la
seule de mes quatre filles à avoir été
conçu porter est mis au monde à camp
lejeune est un ex marine qui a passé un
quart de siècle à camp lejeune
nous l'avons retrouvé sur sa terre parmi
ces arbres fruitiers
en 1985 il a perdu sa fille jenny elle a
succombé à un cancer à l'âge de 9 ans
wen jibao sexuelle à l'âge de 6 à on lui
a diagnostiqué une leucémie
quand la poussière retombe et que le
choc du diagnostic s'estompe
la première réaction est de se demander
pourquoi
elle m'ignore met la main sur des
documents que la navy aurait voulu
garder secret il prouve qu'elle était au
courant dès le début des années 80 de la
présence de plusieurs contaminants dont
le tc eux dans l'eau potable de la base
il part en croisade contre son ancien
employeur la puissante n'est pas contre
le gouvernement
il faut être déterminé à défaut de quoi
vaut mieux abandonner coin en 2012 il
obtient une victoire éclatante une loi
spéciale signée par le président obama
elle porte le nom de sape et jenny la
loi donne aux moeurs line et à leurs
familles accès aux soins de santé pour
plusieurs maladies en lien avec le tc
eux
elle oblige aussi le ministère américain
de la défense a financé des études
épidémiologiques
oui à des failles il a fallu se battre
parce que la navy menacé de ne pas
financer les études j'ai déjà les au
congrès plusieurs fois
on a publié ces dernières années une
série d'études sur l'exposition au tc à
camp lejeune le jeune il y a eu des
expositions fort complexe qui a duré
longtemps mais cette fois c'était dans
l'eau potable plutôt que par inhalation
phénomène plus court 1 en milieu de
travail
ça soulève des questions importantes
quant aux risques pour cette communauté
dirige la ts dr l'agencé fédéral voué à
l'étude des substances toxiques et des
maladies qui sont associés elle est
chapeautée par les six d'ici nous menons
plusieurs études pour comprendre les
risques à la santé des anciens
combattants et d'autres personnes
exposées à camp lejeune
pour y arriver il faut évaluer les
conditions auxquelles ces personnes ont
été exposées
notre rôle est de répondre aux
préoccupations de la communauté quant à
leur exposition à des déchets dangereux
l'agencé étudie les registres de
mortalité de plus de cent cinquante
mille militaires et civiles à camp
lejeune est lui à comparer à ceux de
kantène d'automne une autre base des
muezzins californie c'est
l'épidémiologiste fringues bové qui a
publié ses recherches en 2014 vont
analyser les causes de mortalité en
comparant le camp lejeune à une autre
base militaire semblable ou l'eau
potable n'a pas été contaminé c'est une
bonne comparaison nous avons réussi à
identifier quelques cancer dont
l'incidence était plus élevé à camp
lejeune en particulier le cancer du rein
las luces émis et le myélome multiple
l'étude s'ajoutent aux connaissances et
à la preuve scientifique
la science est le fondement de tout
évidemment si elle est valable
ça prend des dirigeants qui ont le
courage d'affronter leurs supérieurs
qui eux peuvent subir une pression
politique pour étouffer en quelque sorte
le cas du temps le jeune en janvier
dernier son groupe remporté une autre
victoire
le département américain des anciens
combattants levier accepte d'indemniser
les vétérans de camp lejeune
ils n'ont qu'a prouvé qu'ils y ont
séjourné pendant 30 jours
les études ont convaincu levier de
reconnaître la relation entre 8 maladie
et l'exposition au tc eu une
reconnaissance qui devrait lui coûter
plus de 2 milliards de dollars
ces réunions ont lieu trois fois par
annick c'est l'occasion pour les
vétérans de partager leur vécu avec kiel
scientifiques mais aussi de croiser le
fer avec le département des anciens
combattants il exige aujourd'hui que les
compensations soit étendue aux familles
des vétérans mike parti a vu le jour à
camp lejeune en 1968 il ya une dizaine
d'années il apprend qu'il souffre d'un
cancer du sein il se soigne
puis se jette dans l'arène avec genzyme
ignorent
il retrace plus d'une centaine d'hommes
qui ont vécu à camp lejeune et qui sont
aussi atteints du cancer du sein
j'en ai trouvé 10 20 30
j'ai commencé à attirer l'attention on a
fait une étude sur le cancer du sein
chez l'homme on a conclu qu'il y avait
une apparition précoce de ce cancer
le nombre est en très petit on disait
qu'il n'y avait pas la puissance
statistique pour obtenir un résultat
mais c'est une maladie rare comment
arrive-t-on à trouver les chiffres pour
répondre aux critères le nombre de cas
est ce qu'on appelle la puissance
statistique en attend suffisamment pour
déceler un problème quand on a peu de
cas on dit que le résultat obtenu n'aura
pas une puissance statistique suffisante
de l'épidémiologiste reach clap a été
impliqué dans une cause célèbre à urbino
massachusetts dans les années 80 il a
alors constaté un nombre anormal de
leucémies chez les enfants qui avaient
bu de l'eau contaminée au tc il y avait
suffisamment de cas colligées par mike
parking pour justifier conciatore c'est
un drapeau rouge
c'est pourquoi l'étude du cancer du sein
chez l'homme a été réalisé et qu'elle
sera intégré à une plus grande étude sur
l'incidence des cancers
on peut dire que les résultats
préliminaires ont levé un drapeau rouge
il fallait étudier la question pour l'
agence américaine la question d'appui
sans statistique n'est pas un obstacle
elle continuera d'étudier les cas de
cancer du sein chez les hommes même
s'ils ne sont pas très nombreux il faut
évaluer la situation dans son ensemble
on ne peut pas simplement la racheter
quand on observe tous ces cancers qui
surviennent à la suite d'une exposition
aux mêmes produits chimiques moins bien
qu'il ya un problème
au retour la tension monte chez les
experts
[Musique]
il me semble que les citoyens ont posé
cette question est ce que nous notre
population qui a début de l'eau
contaminée est ce qu'on est à risque
d'avoir développer certains cancers
disons que je sois un citoyen de chacun
je m'attendrais qu'on fasse tout ce qui
est possible pour répondre à cette
critique pierre band et le président du
comité conseil
il est un pionnier de l'oncologie et de
l'épidémiologie du cancer le comité
conseil a émis des recommandations très
précises
basé sur les données nouvelles que le
centre international de recherche sur le
cancer avait misé et dont la santé
publique n'a pas tenu compte
en 2012 il y ait consensus scientifique
le centre international de recherche sur
le cancer confirme que le
trichloroéthylène est un cancérigène
reconnu l'année précédente
l' agence de protection environnementale
américaine y pied en étaient venus aux
mêmes conclusions dans une petite
communauté
on n'a pas la puissance statistique de
tous aller et études qu'on aimerait
faire avec la durée d'exposition qu'ils
ont eue les méthodes qui est à ma
disposition et avec leurs faiblesses
ben j'ai pas pu mettre en évidence des
problèmes de santé importants
eux ils disent vous avez pas répondu à
notre question ils ont l'impression
qu'une résistance de votre part la
résistance et les méthodologique et
scientifique
elle n'est pas j'aurais aimé pouvoir
faire une étude comme il le souhaite
mais des conditions pour le réaliser ne
sont pas disponibles
la recherche tire à sa fin le comité
conseil qui avait d'abord envoyé une
proposition commune de pousser l'étude
est maintenant divisée d'un point de vue
scientifique d'un point de vue
d'avancement des connaissances on aurait
toujours plus et ça fait partie des
choses qui auraient pu être explorées
mais ça généreux fait partie du comité
conseil elle est médecin spécialiste en
santé publique et dirige aujourd'hui la
dsp en estrie je pense que de se poser
la question c'est tout à fait cinglant
folie fallait se poser la question mais
j'étais aussi très à l'aise avec la
réponse qu'ils ont été offerts mais tous
ne songe pas à l'opinion de la santé
publique
la moitié des experts reste campé sur
ses positions et les relations sont de
nîmes
dans le cas de la santé publique il y a
eu plusieurs ingérence que j'ai
considéré comme déplorable en
particulier de faire venir de colombie
britannique
un des membres de notre comité conseil
pour avoir une discussion avec lui dont
je ne faisais pas partie
j'ai pas considéré que c'était une façon
de faire légitime
en ce qui me concerne personnellement
celui qu'on fait venir de colombie
britannique c'est le docteur tom
cossette qui travaille à la santé
publique à vancouver
il avait qualifié la version
préliminaire du rapport d' erreur
conceptuelle majeur vous l'avez fait
venir de colombie britannique
oui je pense que oui on lui a expliqué
notre proposition
il a attendu la réponse finale qu'on a
déposé pilote son opinion a changé et
comment dépasser d'erreur conceptuel
majeur est un bon rapport et je l'en dos
vous devriez lui poser la question à
quelques semaines de la publication du
rapport l'expert des citoyens clos
tremblay et expulsé du comité par le dr
desbiens
j'ai vraiment eu l'impression que
j'étais un peu l'empêcheur de tourner en
rond celui qui faisait en sorte que les
choses allaient bouclier françois divier
n'accepte pas qu'il a utilisé les
données du rapport préliminaire
monsieur tremblay les utiliser pour une
représentation en cours pour défendre
heureusement des citoyens en plus qu'à
proposer des choses comme études qui
disent qu'ils ont des vestes majeur tout
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que les
propositions qui sont faites en soit ça
veut pas dire qu'elles sont excellentes
et faisable
à la conclusion de l'étude le docteur
bande de reproche au directeur d'avoir
miné le travail du comité conseil il
estime que l'indépendance du comité n'a
pas été respecté il remettra sa
démission
on avait un mandat qui nous donnait
l'occasion de manifester notre façon
voir su ce que soumettait la santé
publique c'était dans un certain sens
court circuiter l'importance du
comité-conseil et c'est pas une chose à
laquelle j'étais habitué il ya instances
de santé publique la suisa des kilos
pour supporter tous les traitements des
déclarations ont fait comme travail et
il est arrivé en conclusion que ce qu'on
me proposait le procès pollara mais est
ce que ça veut dire que les petites
populations sont condamnés à pas avoir
d' études de qualité
c'est une très bonne question que je
répondrais oui des petites populations
exposé à des contaminants à des doses
inacceptable mais faibles font
apparaître très peu de maladies
il aurait fallu aller plus loin il
aurait fallu tenter de faire un lien
entre l'exposition et les cancers
ça n'a jamais été fait je crois qu'on
s'est arrêté trop tôt
cosworth l'étude aurait pu enrichir la
littérature et jeter un éclairage sur
les produits chimiques qui causent des
cancers
cette contamination est important pour
les citoyens qui ont été exposés ce
n'est pas anodin
il ya eu des répercussions importantes
pour cette communauté
pour cette raison il aurait fallu
poursuivre l'étude et ne pas arrêter à
mi chemin trim
pour moi je fais assez pragmatique mais
je me dis j'ai un moment donné quand
j'ai vu qu'on en cabine certaines
déviations vers cet intérêt lors de
recherches scientifiques je suis revenue
j'ai relu le mandat et je ne crois pas
que les citoyens ont comme préoccupation
qu'on passe des publications
scientifiques
vous vouliez pas faire avancer les
connaissances scientifiques aux jeux
production voulait pas mais pour moi
c'était un une idée parallèle qui peut
être intéressante mais qui répondent à
pau un autre mandat initial disons qu'il
est en approche scientifique ayant une
approche administrative donc la
direction de santé publique ces mails a
pris une approche plus administrative
elle suivait vraiment leur propre
protocole donc c'est un exercice même
futur ça ne change pas le fait que les
citoyens ont subi le préjudice
l'étude de la direction de santé
publique a coûté cinq cent mille dollars
les travaux ont duré près de quatre ans
pas plus de cancers à shannon pas de
nouvelles recherches
le docteur françois desbiens estime
qu'il a fait son devoir en interdisant
la consommation de l'eau après la
découverte du tc eux à shannon les
citoyens souhaitait que l'étude de la
santé publique donne du poids à leur
combat judiciaire en établissant un lien
de causalité
elle aura plutôt servi d'armes pour la
partie adverse je recevais des appels à
la maison je voudrais les appels de des
chercheurs d'un peu partout à travers le
canada
kim téléphone et qui me disait
n'abandonnez pas n'abandonnez pas ne
vous laissez pas faire
si c'est un produit qui est dangereux
qui cause plusieurs cancers il faut
faire de la recherche supplémentaires
qui check je ne dis mais c'est pas des
sponsors pour mon histoire mon affaire
en histoire avec santé publique puis
ça fait qu'on en attend peut-être plus
grand-chose de santé publique
aujourd'hui puisque on a l'impression
qu'on doit se débrouiller par nouveau
demain
après la pause on fait un retour sur
l'une de nos enquêtes le scandale à la
société immobilière du québec
[Musique]
il ya certainement de façon importante
des fautes de gestion et d prudente
c'est la vérificatrice générale et elle
confirme ce qu'ont révélé ya un an en
quête c'est à dire que la société
immobilière du québec en fait d'énormes
concessions pour vendre trois immeubles
du gouvernement des concessions d'au
moins 18 millions aux acheteurs isabelle
et ça en plus il y avait 13 millions de
rénovation que le gouvernement au pays
pour des immeubles où il était devenu
simple locataire pour écouter un extrait
de reportage de l'an dernier des
transactions de plus de 250 millions de
dollars sont sur le point de se faire
les policiers ont enquêté cinq ans pour
échafauder une théorie sur ce qui s'y
trame et dans les bureaux de la société
immobilière du québec à cette époque
c'est la plus grande fraude immobilière
qui aurait eu lieu je pense au québec et
au canada
glass québec à côté du parlement et mise
en vente les acheteurs retenu
deviendront des vedettes de la
commission charbonneau guy gionet alors
pdg de solim le bras immobilier du fonds
de solidarité ftq fait alliance avec
tony accurso qui se passe de
présentation aux professions improbable
[Musique]
guy gionet a expliqué aux enquêteurs
pourquoi sollima cure so hot embauche
chez williams bike l'aide pour les aider
à négocier
il disait qu'il avait un accès
privilégié auprès de gens à la sic qui
lui permettait de l'aider dans la
négociation et de favoriser à son
avantage la négociation avec quel genre
la sic par athlète avait-il des accès
privilégiés
le président est celui qui négociait le
vice président pierre fournier brigitte
m'a dit qu'il contrôlait le conseil de
la sic
au terme des négociations les acheteurs
estime avoir fait une bonne affaire
un prix réduit un bail de 20 ans avait
classique et 10 loyer majoré de 30 6%
avez vous été témoin de cadeaux et où
montant d'argent que baseball kate
aurait remis à un ou des dirigeants de
la cik témoin non mais bill parlait
qu'il était très près des dirigeants et
qu'il s'en servait pour faciliter la
négociation
moi j'en ai conclu que s'il avait ces
résultats-là s'entraîne et possiblement
des contreparties alors marino qui sont
les responsables
notre reportage révélait que la police
enquête sur des allégations pots-de-vin
concernant plusieurs personnes dont l'ex
pdg de la société immobilière marc andré
fortier et trois collecteurs de fonds du
parti libéral du québec
william mbaye tlet charles rondeau et
franco fava tout le monde évidemment nié
ces allégations moment du reportage dont
on peut écouter un autre extrait nous
avons tenté d'obtenir la version des
faits de franco fava
sur l'ensemble des allégations dans
notre reportage
il nie avoir des comptes à l'étranger et
peu reçu en date 24 décembre 2004
transfert de 200 mille dollars dans
votre compte
un as madame je ne suis pas au point de
renier
j'ai rien à vous dire favier d'arrêter
l'eau avez vous été arrêté
nous avons également offert à charron
doux l'occasion de s'expliquer je veux
parler de transactions à la société
immobilière puis je veux parler de votre
compte de banques en autriche aussi il
ne nous a jamais rappelés
ce sont des gens qui se sont associés de
façon très ouverte à l'époque avec le
premier ministre qui était en poste
on sait que c'est des gens qui se sont
affichés comme des amis du premier
ministre c'est le quotidien des gens les
enquêteurs du pack par définition
lorsqu'on est inquiètant criminalité
organisée qui m'ont été financé à
organiser ou encore eu psion on est
toujours nécessaire gouvernementales
mais l'on se rendait compte qu'on était
pas mal proche premier étage la
vérificatrice générale poursuit son
enquête mais cette fois ci sur certains
renouvellements de baux à la société
immobilière et cette question love fait
d'ailleurs partie aussi de l'enquète de
l'upac une enquête qui vous le savez est
longue
commencé il y a très longtemps
d'ailleurs moment de diffuser notre
reportage tant qu'athlète est presque
terminé finalement il ya eu changement
des équipes de procureurs
alors on a renvoyé les enquêteurs faire
leur devoir mais l' enquête est toujours
en cours selon nos informations donc on
va continuer de suivre cela en 2018
assurément parce que c'est déjà la
dernière émission avant la pause des
fêtes
on vous souhaite une excellente période
des fêtes on a déjà hâte de vous
retrouver alors très joyeuse fait de la
part de toute l'équipe et on se retrouve
en janvier pour d'autres enquêtes
[Musique]